well with the announcement last week
that Democratic candidate Bernie Sanders
is dropped out of the race it has now
become clear
it is Trump versus Biden all right so as
you can imagine this must be a very
exciting time at the joe biden for
president headquarters I thought I'd
stop in and well I don't know just
experience some of the joy so let's do
that now please welcome Biden's 2020
campaign manager Jane Sinclair hello
Janey there hey Conan hey so a Bernese
out that's the big news must be very
exciting time over there at the Biden
campaign yeah sure it's uh it's great
okay I'm sorry you just you don't seem
that excited yeah of course we are like
yay Joe Biden
okay I'm sorry your his campaign manager
shouldn't you be more excited about it
more fired up um I am it's great I mean
I'm not gonna vote for Trump and I guess
I will vote for Biden you guess you'll
vote for Biden okay wait a minute
I'm confused there's so much you should
be touting right now like aren't you
excited about things on his platform
yeah he has policy stop
you know it's Biden okay he's fine he's
fine like you know what you're getting
it's like come on Conan Conan you know
what I mean look you're his campaign
manager you are sort of the tip you're
the nosecone of the rocket here isn't a
job to get people really excited about
Joe Biden okay Conan I just I just want
to say we are not all a hundred percent
sure about this guy today he asked me if
I was the new coffee girl okay well he
must have a lot of new staffers I'm
guessing that I've worked for him for 12
years
yep well what's the main strategy there
between now and November what about that
oh he's just trying to you know we're
trying to get out his name and his
message okay that's good and has that
has that worked yeah well if you google
Joe Biden he is now the second person to
come up and that is a pretty good thing
yeah second huh okay well find a way to
get people excited between now and
November right November oh okay I have
we are getting excited over here okay
earlier we did a bite and chant you know
like a like a give me a B give me an i
and by the time we got to dijo was
already asleep and we all got to go home
so that that is excitement yeah oh he's
going to vote right you're going to vote
on Election Day you're going to vote I
am I'm going to vote for Joe Biden
yeah great well you you you lit a fire
under people thank you Jane and welcome
great job okay James Sinclair everybody
I need some wine
you're still on camera